As we talked about computational photography, let's not forget the most basic
element of computational photography is still a camera, camera like this one.
This was actually built in the,
about the mid-1950s, and was given to my father by his father.
And I was lucky enough to get it from my father recently.
This was the first camera I ever used to take my first ever picture.
The bottom line with all cameras is they're still the same in principle.
What they do is they capture rays of light and
get it to a sensor, which can be a digital sensor or film.
And that pipeline is then used to create a photograph.
In this lecture we will talk about that pipeline.
How rays of light are brought onto a sensor to generate a picture.
The most basic example of that camera is a pinhole camera.
And the concept of pinhole photography was known even in the early 300 BC.
But, in about the early 1800s, that was converted into creating cameras.
And from there on, a lot more efforts went into building optics and
lenses that were then used to create better cameras.
In this lecture we'll talk about the pinhole camera.
And we'll talk about the use of lenses to actually get the right kinds of
rays of light to the right location, so we can actually store images.